with the recent legalization of
marijuana and colorado talk of ganja's
all the rage today is it harmful is it
harmless should it be legal should it be
illegal what kind of authority does the
federal government have the problem is
that a lot of information out there is
dead wrong
so I'm here in Ann Arbor Michigan one of
the first cities to actually
decriminalize the drug and home to a few
more than enthusiastic supporters free
the way in order to get to the bottom of
the issue marijuana should it be
legalized yeah good thing um I
definitely think that it should be legal
yeah I think it's I think it's a good
idea government's cracking down on
unhealthy snacks and vending machines
big gulps ban in New York I'm treating
heard of this good idea a bad idea I
think that it's a good idea I don't want
to say some people have reached the
point where maybe they shouldn't make
their own decisions but I think that's
what it's becoming I think it's kind of
good you know cousin uh no it's better
for everyone's health think marijuana
should be legalized um yeah I don't mean
you can do whatever you want to your own
body except a big gulp to show Oh big
gulp sir all right well see you later
this band this legal now there are some
people who think that the federal
government does not have the authority
to make drugs illegal regardless of how
harmless they may be and that's a fully
legitimate discussion to have however
among everybody that we asked everyone
thought that marijuana should be legal
and not one made a constitutional
argument they all actually said it's way
less harmful than a lot of things like
such as alcohol I think it's just
another drug like alcohol it's not real
harming anyone
it doesn't really cause harm in those
people's life and certainly less harm
than alcohol so considering that this is
the premise under which the discussion
of marijuana legalization is now being
discussed it's important to find out if
it's true so we sat down with dr.
Phyllis Boniface a doctor who
specializes in psychiatric care and more
importantly the possible effects of
marijuana it's actually very damaging
and to compare it with alcohol I mean
just to give you a basis for comparison
humans are designed to metabolize
alcohol on the liver at a certain rate
per hour the brain is largely fat and
this drug is stored in fat and so what
happens is after the intoxication is
long over we have a drug that's hanging
around exerting an effect on your
nervous system for weeks to months
people who smoke at a young age have a
much higher incidence of psychosis and
psychotic disorders I
a former Community College history
teacher who did time in a federal
Christian Zionist drug gulag we think
that there's a gene that predisposes
people to schizophrenia for example
people here work for the
military-industrial complex that kill
people all around the world and when
people are exposed to marijuana they
have an onset of their illness about
three years before we normally would see
it and their psychosis is much worse the
entire drug war is a fraud the reason
why marijuana and other drugs are kept
illegal is because if they were
legalized the Pentagon the CIA and the
White House would miss the money now
forgive me my crazy old pothead speak is
a little rusty but allow me to try and
translate for a second the war on drugs
waged by this government has been
largely ineffective in legalizing drugs
here in the United States I believe that
we would reduce the failed war on drugs
decrease crime and likely see a result
of less overall use as in countries
abroad who have followed such a policy
there's this idea that legalizing
marijuana would free up a ton of space
in our Penitentiary's but it's just not
true I have the numbers here in front of
me okay less than 0.1% of state
prisoners were marijuana possession
offenders with no prior sentences let's
take that a step further
only 1.4 percent of state prisoners were
drug offenders held for crimes only
involving marijuana you said you did
time in a federal penitentiary for
nothing more than marijuana possession
just know just attempt attempted
distribution at end of distribution
what's that exactly well that means I
was trying to sell it when I sold
marijuana to my friends and my customers
I was hiding a community service any
prior infractions uh DUIs so when you
think of prisons filled with people like
this it's actually more like this
okay a few things firstly here in the
United States where marijuana has either
been decriminalized or legalized its
usage tends to increase more than some
of you may know we went to community
high school here in Ann Arbor to ask
teenagers about their experiences with
marijuana
the results were shocked have you ever
smoked marijuana yes Wow
yes I have yep yes did you were so your
mom knows now she does I've been doing
it probably three years now 15 been
smoking for three years you know what I
was doing at 12 playin pogs out of all
the students we'd interviewed only two
had not smoked marijuana their biggest
reason for trying it surprised harmless
there's no bad side effects I don't
think it can be necessarily harmful it's
not like a bad drug it's a plant it's
well yep you mean it's natural yeah so
geranium well after all it's got nothing
on a 16 ounce mr. Pibb but funnily
enough the perception of marijuana being
harmless as largely pushed by today's
marijuana Lobby has statistically
resulted in increased use among
teenagers we know that it affects Milan
ization and Milan ization is what
determines the maturity in the
development of the brain people don't
know it but your brain is actually
developing into your early to mid-20s
when we're altering the myelin ization
we're actually altering the way your
brain will function for the rest of your
life that being said the kids do seem to
think that it might be more prevalent
here than nationally because in Ann
Arbor yes I guess everybody seems test
um shocker
despite what people say the more lenient
the drug laws the more likely people
including kids are to light up what
about the idea that ending the drug war
would reduce crime put drug cartels out
of a job you think maybe these cartels
who operate any illegal activity yeah
probably I mean yeah but I mean the
story you still get that extra revenue
right well it's like you're in Ann Arbor
right it's legal essentially to use it
medicinally we just stopped by the high
school what people do is buy it from the
dispensary get a prescription and they
go sell it at a high school yeah I know
some people that have done that yeah you
know if you let have done that may or
may not yeah yes it appears to be that
people who make money through crime tend
to find another way to make money
through crime
keep the change ya filthy animal so if
we legalize drugs would that really be
better for today's law-abiding citizens
the myth that nobody's ever died from a
THC related accident is just not true
the reason people believe that it hasn't
happened is because it's a tougher
process to go through to test for it you
smell something rabbit fear I can take
your blood alcohol level just by a
breath test you uh you fellas bend or a
bit of booze and have you sucking back
on grandpa's old cough medicine it's not
a Miranda right or anything like that
it's just based on your driver's license
where if I want to get your THC level I
have to get a warrant to take your blood
from you or urine do I want to have it
legal for me to do within the police
have to have more rights to be able to
check you for it
we're wording where do people fall on
that on that line and as a matter of
fact there is some data to suggest that
legalization actually increases crime as
seen here from the LAPD DEA now the
reason the numbers might be different
from the crime increased during the
Prohibition era is because of one key
difference during Prohibition the
American government decided to suddenly
ban an activity in which a vast majority
of Americans engaged in legalizing drugs
you'd be doing the exact opposite you
would now be allowing and in some ways
encouraging a practice in which
currently only a minority of Americans
engage listen at the end of the day I
can understand somebody saying okay
marijuana is harmful legalizing it will
likely result in increased usage and
have possibly some negative societal
ramifications here in the United States
but the federal government does not have
the authority and it's been largely
ineffective in waging the war on drugs
that's a completely legitimate argument
and there can be arguments made on both
sides when I have a problem with however
is the discussion being based on a
premise that is alive that is a huge
disservice to our political discourse
today and more importantly generations
of the future you need any more proof
Palestinians have been
camps for about sixty and you Jews put
them there okay first half I am NOT
Jewish anyways okay you look Jewish
anyways
yeah